[Musique]
bonsoir alors écoutez je vais commencer
cette présentation vous posons une
question jamais savoir qui parmi vos est
au courant que les premiers hommes sont
apparus en afrique avait levé la main
bravo merci les homo sapiens sapiens
c'est à dire les hommes et femmes comme
vous et moi sont apparus pour la
première fois en afrique il y a
exactement 300 milles en sera cela
porterait donc à croire que l'afrique a
une histoire vieille d'au moins 300
mille ans et pourtant l'afrique n'a pas
d'histoire
pourquoi ben parce que la majorité des
africains ne la connaissent pas ils ne
la recherche pas il ne la valorise pas
et surtout on ne lance n y pas c'est un
peu comme si pendant trois cent mille
ans les africains n'avaient rien fait
s'est assis sous les manguiers sous les
cocotiers
ils n'ont rien inventé ils n'ont rien
écrit ils n'ont rien bâti et pourtant
lorsqu'on étudie l'histoire de l'afrique
noire d'avant la période coloniale
il n'y a que des sentiments de fierté et
d'honneur pour ce que nos ancêtres
africains ont bâti avant nous mais que
nous nous obstinons à ignorer
et c'est donc pour toutes ces raisons
que je suis l'auteur de plusieurs
ouvrages sur l'afrique et que j'écris
exclusivement sur l'afrique noire
je m'appelle alain thomas couëffé et ce
soir je vous avais tous pour que main
dans la main nous fassions un voyage
dans le temps à la re découverte de
choses extraordinaires
ce soir nous allons parler de
l'informatique
qu'est-ce que ça que l'informatique
basse est un ensemble de techniques
utilisées pour le traitement automatique
des informations
ce traitement automatique se fera à
partir d'un système de codage un code
binaire
c'est à dire un kodak de chiffres qui va
en fait utilisé les chiffres 0 et ans
pour transcrire toutes les informations
qui existent tels que la musique et les
images
et les transmettre sur les écrans des
appareils électroniques que nous
utilisons aujourd'hui tels que les
téléphones portables les ordinateurs et
aussi les téléviseurs donc une fois que
nous avons cette définition c'est à dire
que nous savons que l'informatique est
basé sur un code binaire qui va utiliser
les chiffres 0 et 1
ne pouvant continuer notre voyage dans
les années 1900 se font plusieurs
découvertes qui vont bouleverser
l'histoire de l'afrique
parmi ces découvertes il ya deux objets
le premier s'appelle l'os de les bonbons
et le deuxième s'appelle l'os d'ishango
en 1950 sur un site de pêche dans le
nord du congo ainsi de pêche qui
s'appelle et chang ou des chercheurs
vont retrouver un objet qui vont appeler
l'hostis chango vous l'avez ici à ma
gauche il était daté au carbone 14 et
les vieux le 27 milan et à ma droite
vous avez des images de sites de pêche
distinguo est derrière moi vous avez la
géo localisation du site de pêche comme
vous le voyez qui se trouvent aux
alentours des sources du nil
juste à titre rappelle nos ancêtres
africains qu'on appelle les nubiens
appelait toutes les régions aux
alentours des sources est une île la
terre où tout a commencé et donc
intéressant ici c'est que cet objet
qu'on appelle l'os d'ishango est d'une
importance capitale pour l'histoire de
l'afrique parce que cet objet nous
allons retrouver l'avènement des
mathématiques
quel genre de mathématiques nous allons
retrouver
nous allons voir les nombres premiers
les nombres impairs la soustraction et
l'addition
donc je vous pose la question qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un nombre premier bain non
au premier c'est un nombre qui est
divisible par un et par lui-même
ne vous inquiétez pas ce soir n'allons
pas faire des mathématiques compliqué et
c'est pour cette raison que je vous
adresser ce tableau qui vous montre les
nombres premiers dans le bon ordre et
juste à côté vous avez l'os d'ishango et
si vous remarquez sur le côté gauche
sous le côté droit il ya des petits
traits ses traits ce sont des encoches
chaque série d'encausse et séparés par
un espace donc ce que j'ai fait c'est
que j'ai les ans tout en rouge pour
permettre le comptage donc nous allons
regarder sur le côté gauche
lorsqu'on regarde tout en haut
nous retrouvons que la première série
l'encoche content content nous obtenons
11 ans coche dans la deuxième série en
obtient très à gauche et ainsi de suite
on obtient 17 et 19
donc je vous pose la question
11 13 17 19 ne font-ils pas partie des
nombres premiers
sur le côté droit
nous avons le même principe lorsque nous
comptons les en cause la première série
en obtient encore une fois le nombre 11
et ensuite on obtient le nombre 21 ans 8
19 et 9 pour ceux qui l'ont remarqué
comme le monsieur est ici ce sont tous
des nombres impairs
lorsque nous comptons tous les chiffres
qui sont du côté droit on n'obtient le
nombre 60
et lorsqu'on compte tous les chiffres du
côté gauche elle obtient encore une fois
le nombre 60
donc je vous dis tout de suite
celle ou celui qui a fait cet objet est
en train de s'amuser en faisant les
mathématiques alors qu'il n'est pas
possible de le faire à moins de
maîtriser les mathématiques
donc nous pouvons dire qu'à travers cet
objet l'os d'ishango nous avons ici la
preuve que la fait que non seulement le
berceau de l'humanité mais aussi le
berceau des mathématiques
pourquoi 1 parce qu'il n'existe pas de
preuves plus vieille que l'os de
l'hérault et l'os d'ishango qui
représente les mathématiques dans le
monde
donc la question logique à se poser
maintenant c'est si cela est le cas
quand est ce que les mathématiques
apparaissent sur les autres continents
pour faciliter la compréhension je vous
ai fait un graphe
vous avez ici de l'an zéro qui
correspond à l'année où jésus christ est
né
c'est ce genre le calendrier qu'on
utilise aujourd'hui donc on va faire bon
usage que ce soit ici je vous présente
le moment où les mathématiques sont
apparus en afrique
il faudra alors attendre six cents ans
avant l'arrivée de jésus christ c'est à
dire en lan mois ci sans pouvoir
apparaître des mathématiques en europe
dans la grèce ancienne
donc si nous faisons la différence entre
le moment les mathématiques sont apparus
en afrique le moment les mathématiques
sont apparus en europe il ya exactement
24 mille quatre cents ans
donc nous pouvons affirmer que l'afrique
a pratiqué les mathématiques pendant
vingt-quatre mille quatre cents ans
avant l'europe
tout à l'heure nous avons parlé du site
opel chiche en go ce qui est intéressant
sur le site de pêche c'est que nous
avons l'utilisation d'outils de pêche un
des outils le plus utilisé c'est le
harpon pourquoi parce que c'est un
instrument très utile pour attraper les
poissons
ici vous avez des exemples de harpon en
fait où est ce que je veux en venir ce
que je veux vous dire c'est que nous
pouvons suivre le flux migratoires de
ces populations de pêcheurs nubien
lorsqu'ils vont se déplacer en afrique
sur les différents sites de pêche comme
en bas tout simplement faisant la
datation au carbone 14 des différents
arts bon que nous allons retrouver sur
les différents sites de pêche et qu'est
ce qu'on découvre des choses
extraordinaires ici nous découvrons que
ces populations de personnes bien vont
quitter les régions des sources du nil
représenté par le chiffre est bon se
déplacer dans trois directions
une partie de cette population va aller
s'installer en afrique de l'ouest le
long du fleuve niger représenté par le
chiffre 2 mais aussi le long du golfe et
la guinée une autre partie de cette
population va quitter les sources est
une île remonter le long du fleuve nil s
installer dans la région qu'on appelle
le soudan mais qu autrefois s'appelait
la nubie représenté par le chiffre trois
est ensuite une autre partie de la
population va quitter les sources du nil
traverser la mer rouge s'installer dans
l'arabie qu'on appelait autrefois
l'afrique du nord est et ensuite pour
des raisons climatiques les populations
dans la région numéro deux et la région
numéro 4 on se déplacer à les rejoindre
leur famille lointaine dont le soudan et
c'est d'ailleurs dans cette région que
va naître la royauté pharaonique 300 ans
avant que ces populations de pêcheurs
nubien nom voit le long du fleuve nil
une vague migratoire qui va s'installer
dans la vallée du nil a colonisé et
créer la plus grande civilisation que le
monde ait connu la situation de l'egypte
ancienne
mais dont le vrai nom est la situation
tu habites qui veut dire
la terre des noirs et donc quand vous
regardez par exemple les hiéroglyphes
vous allez vous rendre compte que une
majeure partie d'entre eux ont été criés
à partir de quoi à partir des images du
type de pêche pourquoi parce que les
influences de ces pêcheurs qui a été
prépondérante dans l'époque
prédynastique et c'est donc pour rendre
hommage à ces populations de pêcheurs
les biens qui sont en fait à la base de
ruyt est pharaonique qu'il vend donc
décidé d'utiliser l'instrument le plus
utile c'est-à-dire le japon il appelait
le japon le roi donc ils vont user le
roi dieu le harpon pour représenter le
commencement le début le départ
c'est-à-dire le chiffre et c'est pour
cette raison que quand vous regardez les
chiffres kamit c'est à dire les chiffres
de l'egypte ancienne
vous voyez que le chiffre au 1 s'appelle
le web exactement comme le harpon et que
le chiffre 1 à la même forme que le
harpon
d'ailleurs pour preuve supplémentaire
lorsqu'on regarde des tombes de certains
pharaons
on trouve des choses extraordinaires
dans ce cas si nous sommes dans la tombe
du pharaon toungui mal à ce pharaon vous
le connaissez sous le nom de
toutankhamon alors toutankhamon ce n'est
pas son nom
ça c'est le nom que les européens lui
ont donné son nom africain c'est toumba
est mal d'ailleurs les burundais et
rwandais dans cette salle comprendront
la signification de ce nom quand on
continue à faire des fouilles
archéologiques
on retrouve aussi l'utilisation du
chiffre zéro vous l'avez ici en haut à
droite et en plus grand en bas le
chiffre zéro s'appelait le nez fourré
l'avouerez veut dire sublime magnifique
et vous allez retrouver le chiffre zéro
dont les tombes des comptables égyptien
pourquoi parce qu'à cette époque quand
quelqu'un mourait on enterrait la
personne avec des objets qui lui étaient
familiers dans l'eau
dugongs d'hab on enterre avec une partie
de son travail et donc si vous
connaissez un peu votre histoire de
l'egypte ancienne vous savez qu'une
grande qu'à 8 une grande prêtresse de
l'egypte ancienne qui s'appelait nafoura
ighirri pourquoi pas tout simplement
parce que à cette époque les africains
considéré que les personnes les plus
foncées le pot et elle est plus belle
mais aussi les plus proches de dieu
parce que dont l'égypte ancienne d'un
dieu étaient représentés de la couleur
noire la plus foncée et ici vous avez
leur représentation de dieu selon
l'egypte ancienne et donc qu'on ce jeune
bébé est né et que les sages femmes ont
vu sa couleur de peau elles ont donc
appelé la forêt qui veut dire la sublime
est en panne et où la magnifique est
arrivé donc qu'est ce qu'on peut dire ce
soit on peut dire ce soit le 15 novembre
2019 que nous avons tous ensemble
re découvert l'origine membres des
sociétés pharaonique mais aussi
l'origine africaine
le chiffre zéro et du chiffre au 1 qui
seront utilisés plus tard pour créer le
système de codage le code binaire à deux
chiffres qui va amener l'ère
informatique dans laquelle nous
retrouvons aujourd'hui on va pas
s'arrêter leurs valets plus loin est ce
que cela veut dire que il a fallu
attendre que l'europe prenne
informatique pour que nous ayons
l'informatique ce n'est pas le cas je
vous explique
j'ai autour de mon cou un chapelet qu'il
est dans la tradition il urba s'appelle
le hawk baylet l'europe de l'est et la
représentation physique d'une science en
scène africaine qu'on appelle la science
ifao la science femme qui est utilisé
par tous les peuples pêcheurs du golfe
de guinée et qui sera mise en place pour
prédire l'avenir acquérez la sagesse ou
apprendre la fin
coupez si vous regardez l'europe élèves
vous voyez que il est fait de courir si
vous regardez l'image qui est derrière
moi vous voyez que le courions de face
la partie convexe du courrier va
représenter le chiffre 1 et la partie
concave du court il va représenter le
chiffre de 2 chiffres
comment est ce que ça marche pas les
initier à cette science en sénat fait
que nous devons prendre l'europe et les
jeter à l'eau pied et par la façon dont
les cours ils vont tomber sur les
parties convexe ou concave et vendant
utiliser le tableau géomantique
clairement qu'ils connaissent par coeur
ils vont prédire l'avenir
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pas ça veut
dire tout simplement que cette science
en scène africaine marche à partir d'un
code à deux chiffres un code binaire qui
sera utilisé pour prédire l'avenir
alors je vous le dit le suit quand on
parle de code binaire on est déjà dans
l'informatique
donc évidemment quand on parle
d'informatique nous sommes obligés de
parler d'ordinateurs pourquoi parce que
les ordinateurs aujourd'hui sont la
représentation physique de
l'informatique
les ordinateurs ont ce qu'on appelle des
processeurs qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
processeur basse le cerveau de
l'ordinateur qui va être utilisé pour le
traitement de l'information mais aussi
pour faire des calculs avancé nous avons
des processeurs qui marcha whip it des
processeurs qui marchent à 16 bits et
des processeurs qui marchent à 32 bits
plus les augmentant le nombre de bits
plus le pouvons faire des calculs avancé
oui bits en informatique
c'est ce qu'on appelle un cocktail un
octet c'était un ensemble de huit
éléments
je vous invite donc à compter le nombre
d'éléments sur l'europe et les 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8
oui cauris oui beat huit éléments un
octet nous avons aussi des processeurs
qui marchent à 16 bits
si nous regardons juste la branche
droite du khoury nous avons quatre de
leurs collègues
nous avons quatre courses mais chakouri
à deux faces donc si nous faisons quatre
à la puissance 2 à l'obtient combien cs
bits et aussi des processeurs qui
marchent à 32 bits
si nous avons 16 sur la branche droite
c'est que bien évidemment nous avons 16
sous la manche gauche
donc si on fait 16 puis 16 on obtient
combien 32 bits
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ben ça veut dire tout simplement que
avant que l'europe ne crée des machines
pour faire des calculs avancée par
l'afrique était déjà dans l'air
informatique l utiliser un code à deux
chiffres basés sur les chiffres 1 et 2
c'est à dire là il m'indiqua base 2 qui
leur permettait en fait d'utiliser
l'ordinateur le plus puissant que dieu
ait créé le cerveau humain et donc je
vais conclure en vous racontant une
histoire qui est très pertinente en 700
après jésus christ apparaît un
personnage qu'on appelle le prophète
mohammed
le prophète mohammed et ses disciples
ont décidé de répondre l'islam dans
l'ouest et dans l'est de l'arabie et
donc ses disciples vont s'installer dans
le nord de l'afrique et vont regarder de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique et voir
l'europe
ils vont donc décidé de conquérir
l'europe et donc pendant 800 en bas les
arabes seront les maîtres d'une partie
de l'europe c'est-à-dire des régions
qu'on appelle le portugal l'espagne et
aussi le sud de la france
c'était facile à cette époque parce que
l'europe était dans ce qu'on appelle
l'âge sombre
c'est à dire la période pendant laquelle
il ne circule plus de connaissances en
europe et c'est donc auprès des
librairies et des livres des arabes que
les européens vont se reconnecter et
apprendre qu'ils avaient les ancêtres
qu'on appelle les grecs le co paris ces
grecs y avait des gens qui s'appelait
thales aristote pythagore socrates et
qu'ils avaient théorisé il avait écrit
inventé bâti et donc ils se sont posé la
question mais si nos ancêtres ont fait
ça vous les arabes fait quoi hisser et
donc c'est comme cela que toute l'europe
à soutenir eva chasser les arabes hors
de l'europe ce qui va suivre
après ça c'est ce qu'on appelle la
période des lumières c'est à dire la
période durant laquelle toute l'europe
va repartir à la source c'est-à-dire
lire les écrits des grecs
leur invention leurs théories leur
philosophie vont s'imprégner de ce que
les grecs ont écrit et ce qui va suivre
après la période des lumières c'est ce
qu'on appelle la renaissance c'est à
dire que les écrits des grecs vont faire
revivre l'europe
l'histoire de l'europe par revivre à
travers ses origines et donc quand je
rencontre très souvent des africains qui
me disent que l'afrique ne changera
jamais et que l'afrique est une terre
maudite et que je lui le désespoir dans
leurs yeux et dans lé en mots c'est
cette histoire là que je le raconte
parce que comme j'aime à le dire ce
n'est que quand on va se mettre
réellement en tête de revenir à nos
racines de lire ce que nos ancêtres ont
fait de reconnecter avec notre histoire
vraie que nous allons obtenir les outils
nécessaires pour la renaissance de
l'afrique
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]